should I his classmates are still in my
play let's no doubt about that so I've
got a little quiz for you are you ready
I wanna find out healthy some option is
biggest hits relate to her life now so
first up who is still the one in your
life my son is my children come on I
love being a mom and yeah he's gonna
always be the one that's up for ever and
for always love for everything almost
baby yeah that's an answer that you
could ever give okay you ready to
complete this sentence for me go any man
of mine has to like my food are you
gonna hook I am a good cook but I don't
always get it right you know but I just
want me to say that you know this is
delicious you went to a lot of trouble
is appreciated
he does something like okay what's your
goatee like if you really want to make
him happy and say okay I got it I got to
get to him tonight what is your dish to
cook I think it's always pasta hmm
even though he won't ever dinner yeah he
always wants me to make him something
that is slimming but he realized
impossible no no he says he wants me to
make something slimming but then you
want spot that all right yeah I know all
right well here's question from a big
fan of charity here nyah okay take a
look
hey Shan Dyer what's something that just
doesn't impress you much these days you
can't get rid of him he wants to know
what something is that just doesn't
impress you much these days
ah you know what does not impress me
disrespect so like you and I we're gonna
we're gonna battle this out with lots of
mutual respect yeah could you say you're
saying he's disrespecting you right now
no I mean I'm just my challenger I'm
just warning him and then okay
we hate tell me last night though that
you kind of wanted to get him on your
show you want to invite him on maybe be
a mentor on real country I would love it
could I take Blake I would love that for
a time or two yeah I mean maybe borrow
is a better word I can give him back
it's kind of like having kids around you
love them but
you want to get them back I gotcha oh
you starts misbehaving I have another
cry when do you most feel like a woman
oh you don't think in a real country and
you know I would say rolling in my speed
baby's arms and I know you were actually
recently saw Celine at her Vegas
residency you guys get a chance to catch
up any chance we might see a duet oh
come on boss what are my dreams it's
always been that she would record one of
my songs so yeah I'd love for her to
sing one of my songs I'm gonna write one
for her I love her she's extraordinary
okay Matt you need to do it well she
doesn't need me I [ __ ] Trudy gonna be
fabulous
I could write the song she could sing it
uh I have to say I would love to hear
Celine Dion sing still the one I would
huh yeah that would be us and they know
Emma for I feel like a woman I guess
ma'am okay I'm sorry thank you so much
for being here
what a treat it was to have you here and
you can see more Shania tight on USA is
a real country yes and feel good keeping
it real
[Music]
[Applause]